شكرًا لك ،
أعتقد أن هذا البلد
هو العثور على خيارات أخرى موجودة فقط على اليسار
أو اليمين
أو الأحمر أو الأزرق [
موسيقى] [
تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هو شخص مؤهل تمامًا وليس لي ،
لذلك يقلقني أنه سيكون
المسؤول ، لا أعتقد أن لديه
القدرة على
إنهاء هذا الفصل ، أتمنى آسف
وأعتقد أن هذه ليست فكرة رائعة ،
ولا أعتقد أنه سينجح
[موسيقى] ،
نعم ،
لا أرى أيًا منها  تشالنجر ديمقراطي آخر
من شأنه أن
يحصل على التصويت
وبصراحة أنه سيفوز مرة أخرى بعض
المحترفين هم حرفياً أنك تعلم أننا
لا نتعامل مع جنون ترامب أه
أعني أن هذا كان ساحقًا جدًا بالنسبة
لي سأصوت له مرة أخرى ما لم يكن
أحدًا  مع ربما أصغر قليلاً على
وجه التحديد مع امرأة
مثل كمالا [
موسيقى] ،
نحتاج إلى شيء ربما
لا تتوقعه البلدان الأخرى بقدر ما يتعلق
بالأمن لأنهم يعرفون مكانهم
مع ترامب يعرفون مكانهم
باستخدام الكتاب المقدس.  لون البشرة على
الإطلاق أريد شخصًا لديه بعض
الأفكار الجديدة الجيدة وليس مجرد صراع على السلطة
[موسيقى]
أجنبي